what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I am going to be
reacting to the Andrew Tate Vice
documentary so um a little background
I was notified after the show that I
just did that um Andrew Tate released
the video
um basically that he that Vice did a hit
piece on him so now he did a hit piece
back and apparently Vice is also going
under
rumored allegedly so let's let's get
this reaction started roll the clip
blessing
so let me tell you all a quick story
about Vice news remember Vice news
I know they don't learn
I allowed them to come and do a piece on
me in the war room
about seven months ago now
I knew it would be a hit piece of course
I'm a professional but I also knew
anyone with the brain would see through
the hit piece to see the beauty of
to join so I allowed them to come do a
hit piece
and then
I got interviewed by Piers Morgan I'll
look for calling
it's our friends from Vice but he can
wait
then I interviewed by Piers Morgan and
he came at me hard and all of the
comments are saying bro takes a g The
Matrix tries to tell the world that
everyone hates me but the truth is
everyone actually loves me so when peers
tried to come for me hard expecting to
be a hero he was actually attacked and
he felt like oops I made a mistake which
stopped Vice releasing their hit piece
because they called me and said hey
don't call him
he called me that hey we want to film
some more we feel like we didn't get the
other side of the story basically we
want to undo the hit piece and do the
fair journalism we were supposed to do
in the first place because now we
realize making a hit piece on you
doesn't work out well for us
then I went to jail because I'm Matrix
attacked and I thought ah he's a bad guy
now we can do a hit piece and they
released a hit piece and nobody believed
it just like I said everyone saw through
it salt was garbage to the point where
Vice had to turn the comments off
because everyone was insulting them they
even falsely edited me stuttering when
have you ever seen me stutter on any
video ever to try and make me look
frustrated like I've been caught out by
this dork called Matt
so they released a hit piece and it was
totally detrimental for them nobody
believed them Bond their reputation even
worse Vice used to be something and now
they're completely off the deep end
nobody gives a [__] about them come
complete Matrix propaganda
so now you're released from Jada
and now Matt from Vice is begging me
begging me for another interview
calling me every day Tate come here
we didn't do you like that
you know what I mean only good things I
just probably think
come sorry sorry I I had to plug I had
to plug this is so entertaining hey
begging me
please please please
talk to side because I'm such a nice man
most people have a hit piece done about
them and they don't talk to that
organization anymore but I'm so nice
I'm gonna have a conversation with Vice
news we're gonna talk this man is the
most entertaining man on the planet
your house
that's just a mean question Matt
that's just a mean question like where
else
[Laughter]
you know
whatever and I think you learned that
when you turn the comments off in your
little video that most people understand
I'm a Force for good and that hit pieces
did they turn the comments off on the
video I did for advice they do that I
did a four hour video with Vice and they
edited it down it might have been longer
than that they added it down to like 45
minutes I made some points I wish I
could react to the vice video but I
think they would copyright me right I
think I tried once and they didn't let
me
this is so funny
it is the funniest man alive
don't really work I don't know because
you've lost all credibility the
mainstream Matrix mechanisms of the
media unfortunately for you someone just
said they won't be able to copyright
uses they're going bankrupt
[Laughter]
should we do it next
should we do it next listen wait until
the fire for bankruptcy we're gonna hit
something yeah yeah certain device
reactions are coming oh we'll react the
hell out of ice
talk about some things the lady advice
was rude to me all right okay yeah I
have an issue with this Vice lady I was
asking them oh could I see your control
room could I see your panel now maybe
she's in her right to say no
but you know I bet she needs a job now
[Laughter]
you know baby had
we had an opening but I don't know it I
know you know we did have it yeah but it
was like they had so many producers and
[__] now and I kept asking like why they
needed so many people because I was
trying to produce my stuff
I think our [__] looks better than
theirs
pearly flat at Tate's Place to interview
him I would what the
whenever they want we're on our way
tomorrow Andrew I'm going to get my Visa
stamped you know what I mean I mean I
didn't have multiple possible slack
queue you know I'm from Africa but I'm
gonna get it tomorrow okay do you know
how hard it is for this man to travel I
I couldn't believe it
I want to get my Romanian Visa too I'm
coming
I'm manifested
everyone on the planet wants to
interview me so the question is why
would I choose you when I have unlimited
offers from people who are far more
successful and better than you at the
job
because I'd be doing and I'm not trying
to disrespect you I'm being honest I'd
be doing you a favor like Matt we'll
take the favor we'll take it
yeah
yeah I know you probably got better
offers I won't lie to you
so why would I do an interview with you
and this isn't genuinely a question it's
not an insult I'm actually asking you
why I would choose you when I have
unlimited offers on the table
because we have a history
[Laughter]
sounds like a ex-girlfriend we had a
history yeah it doesn't I was the guy
let's be honest with each other we have
a history we're friends now don't lie
Stoppers were edited in to try and make
it look like you stunked me with your
asinine questions which of course is
absolutely impossible
[Laughter]
sometimes we got to b-roll of someone's
face when we're editing an interview
because you know we spoke for almost an
hour but it gets cut down to only a few
minutes so there are going to be some
edits and we are going to come to your
face at some point
um you dishonestly edited okay we agree
yeah that's what they do you go into
your boss's room and ask if you're
allowed to spend
a large portion of your salary on a five
pound box of chocolates and you let me
know and if you can then I will strongly
consider allowing you
you want to
we'll do it where how much chocolate we
gotta bring we'll do it we'll do it
are you asking all the journalists to
bring you a box of chocolates what math
doesn't know is that because he's a
dishonest journalists if he agrees to
the trumpets I'll agree to the interview
what we're gonna do is record him
standing around waiting for the
interview with my box chocolates
yeah
no he's not
is Anthony coming out to meet us
um yeah who are you Matt this is Matt
and he looks from the BBC all right I'm
gonna let you actually win okay what do
you actually win
be right back okay
I think you can see him stand outside my
house right there
and I was like
[Laughter]
likes Mariah Carey like look he's been
playing a lot
yeah she's a Vibe still
why are you so obsessed with me
if you or take can cover the way where
we're both happy then you're not gonna
get an interview without the chocolate
yeah you know that's fine so how about
uh if you tell he can come out and then
we can hand him the chocolate as we
enter and you can film it
okay I'm gonna tell him but he's pretty
busy
what is the cameraman for me the focus
yo why is to why do you have your eye on
the thing like it's 20 23 like why did
you bring that big thing what's going on
there man uh look so I know you want to
film you want to film us giving you the
chocolate so
um I you know I'm happy for you to do
that I just as I'm sure you know like I
don't want to risk a situation where I
give you the chocolate and then uh we
don't get in so why don't we do
something like you come out and you know
we speak face to face and I give you the
chocolate as we walk in
[Music]
after Matthew
so I made payment in advance
unfortunately
well can you suggest a way in which we
can uh find you know feel some sort of
assurance that you're gonna speak to us
like maybe if you come out now and we
can hand it to you face to face
the problem is last time I trusted you
and you acted in bad faith so this time
you must trust me that's the circle of
life
must place your faith in the top G and
hand over the chocolate the payment for
his presence
but this is
not me allowing you unprecedented access
to my private Network and Home in which
you were a bad faith actor if you still
are scared about losing your heavy
Financial investment of six pounds in a
box of chocolates then you will not get
your interview well it's a hard line the
thing is
you know I'm a journalist
yes you can't just
yeah yeah
I should have just left the chocolates
you know I mean
you know you can't just assume that big
enough
imagine a world in which
no he didn't get the chocolate no he's
pretending like he's talking to Tate he
hung up the phone call
he's talking to himself right now
yeah but you know who would do that
let's watch the video
well he said is give you chocolate right
so if I give if you give you a square of
chocolate no
okay see you
one hour later damn he didn't give him
the chocolate we guessed wrong
put it all in the chat put a one in the
chat if you thought he was gonna get the
chocolate put a two in the chat if you
didn't I can't read it can you read it
what does it say is it uh you said it
must be weird having a boss and Matt was
it is sadly I'm driving away now call me
when you are next free
it was him holding the chocolate in a
plane in the uh it is a broken life
should I join the War Room
[Laughter]
oh yeah
foreign
that's the bankruptcy
yeah
oh wouldn't be wouldn't it be funny if
Tate buys Vice oh that would be so funny
oh Mr T that's the chess move you've
been waiting for oh
yeah how crazy it is it to be valued at
5.7 billion and then to go to nothing
yeah [__] happen when you do hit
pieces on people you know
yeah because here's the thing like
people know what's true and what's not
true and they might not immediately but
when people do bad faith reactions when
people do bad faith Clips they might not
figure it out right away but in the long
run the test of time shows character it
shows what people are about and the
people aren't stupid they start to see
through it they start to see [__]
and the truth of the matter is a bunch
of these reaction channels and news
places don't care about the truth they
don't care about what's right and the
only thing they care about is making
their money and getting their coin and
criticizing everyone along the way and
they just sit there on hours and hours
and hours of you talking waiting for
something that they can take out of
context
but here
I'll adjust pearly things Network
we believe in freedom of speech yes sir
we believe let's go we believe in
freedom of speech we believe in giving a
platform to those who have been
de-platformed and we believe
and stopping all this goddamn [__]
from these reactions I'm so tired of
these people calling this man these
reaction channels have been saying that
Tate committed a crime that he didn't
commit if that can happen to the average
man or I'm sorry if that can happen to a
man with money power and Status what
happens to the average guy
there's no chance Tate could fight these
accusations but the guy next door he
can't do [__]